juillet toujours dans la région ponote
décidément une région qui ne cesse de
faire parler d'elle donc puisqu'elle
produit une pièce d'avenir en matière
médicale il s'agit de ligaments en temps
réel et oui en fait c'est très très
sérieux puisque 15 personnes jusqu'à
présent de par le monde possède une
dentelle du puy dans leurs articulations
cette rencontre est prêt pour cette
rencontre
évidemment abîmé ils sont remplacés par
me dit pièces que vous avez vu en
dentelle et qui devait se passer les
différents liquides et le gigot jm
manille 7 pièces de dentelles la rule et
je dois avouer qu'à l'heure actuelle il
ya quinze personnes qui portent une
dentelle dans leur corps et je pense
étant donné qu'il n'y a pas eu pour
l'instant de rejet que c'est appeler à
un grand développement
c'est ici dans cet atelier conservatoire
du fion dentelle à l'aide de 116 fuseaux
et à partir de fils de polyéthylène
haute tension et haute performance
les pièces destinées à remplacer des
ligaments d'articulation humaine genoux
et chevilles notamment batteur de
travail sont nécessaires pour réaliser
une pièce dont l'élasticité doit être
plus importante dans un sens que dans
l'autre ce qui a entraîné l'invention
d'un nouveau point les points
professionnels ne permettant pas d'avoir
cette élasticité dans le bon sens il a
fallu que faire des recherches et créer
un promo qui permettent le l'asti cité
dans le sens désiré par hasard dans la
personne qui nous a commandé ce travail
ça nécessitait le dépôt d'un brevet
exactement il a fallu déposer le point
pour pouvoir le protéger tant donné
c'est un point de vente est absolument
nouveau en tant que dessinateur il a
fallu aussi calibrage le suppose au
millimètre après tout ces guerriers
absolument puisque l'espacement des
épingles est très important dans le
travail de la dentelle et pour respecter
les dimensions donné il a fallu faire
une recherche justement sur cette épave
espacement pour avoir le meilleur
résultat
cent vingt pièces ont déjà été réalisés
depuis 1987 à destination d'un
laboratoire spécialisé dans les
prothèses et appareils chirurgicaux
ainsi avec cette tradition séculaire
l'atelier conservatoire duffy s'est mise
en quelque sorte au service de la
chirurgie du troisième millénaire
nous n'allons pas faire d des milliers
de petites pièces de dentelle mais c'est
si vraiment cela prend le développement
que j'espère est bien ce soit
l'industrie qui en profitera
dans tous les cas un plus pour vous
transparent à oui et cela justifie notre
création quelque sorte
et comme pour couronner entre guillemets
cette première mondiale l'atelier
conservatoire s'est fixée un tout autre
objectif réaliser sur le plus grands
carreaux du monde de mettre 24 de long
drapeau tricolore aux dimensions
officielles qui nécessitera plus de 2500
heures de travail et 1995 ont exactement
la tradition active a donc rendez vous
avec l'histoire d'hier et de demain